let's keep moving through our phone
lines where we now have 20 people
holding 617 830 4750 is the number will
go to our next caller from the 714 area
code caller what's your name where are
you calling from and and what's your
question today hey what's up pac-man my
name is art and i'm calling from anaheim
california great and so my question is
I'm like what what do you think the end
game is for the Democrats and this whole
Russia thing because I mean like what
happens when the Democrats win the White
House and 2020 are they are they still
going to be escalating this Russia thing
I mean are we can go to war I mean like
what's going to happen once Trump is out
and a Democrat is in okay good question
two angles to this right number one is
this there are some so-called
investigations that are purely political
and as soon as who's in power changes
you forget about it so like the whole
Locker up thing Trump's going to
investigate Hillary and blah blah blah
the day he gets elected all of a sudden
it's no longer a priority right I do not
believe the Russia investigation falls
under that umbrella it's going to
continue until there is a resolution
period regardless of who wins in 20 18
or 20 20 if it takes that long but I
actually am a little concerned with the
angle of what's the Democratic end game
with the Russia investigation I am
against the concept that it should be a
partisan thing it's become partisan
because clearly there are so many blind
Trump follower Republicans that are
saying hey even though there's an insane
amount of smoke we're going to just keep
saying there's no fire I believe that
this is an issue of both national
security and sovereignty and the
legitimacy of the presidency and I don't
like talking about it in partisan terms
because it really shouldn't be I think
that this is an investigation that
should be done fully and objectively
regardless of who's in power to its full
conclusion
yeah yeah I agree I mean there's the
sentence definitely something there and
I mean I don't know which is I guess
we'll see what happens we will we will
thanks so much for the call really
really appreciate it important topic and
we've got to try to I know it's insane
but we've got to try to depoliticize
what's going on with Russia